- I don't know how you skinny
people do this shit.
- (upbeat music)
- So my friend Curly
told me his resolution
this year is to get in shape,
except he hates working out.
Well, the good news is I love working
out, so I'm gonna help him out. Hi Curly.
- Hey.
- So you don't like working out,
but we're gonna figure
out what you do like.
- Okay.
- Would you rather be inside or outside?
- Inside.
- Alone or with a group of people?
- I'd say alone, but I don't
mind one other person or so.
- Would you say that you're like,
an intense person or more chill?
- I'd say more chill, I
hate when like, you make
that ugly face when you're
getting really into it
and I don't want to make that ugly face.
- Okay, okay, I think this is gonna
be easy. I'll call ya later.
- Okay.
- I figured out something
I think Curly might like,
so I told him to get changed
and meet me at my apartment.
- Let's do this.
- What is this outfit?
- It's all I have to wear.
- I think I have created a
workout that you might not hate.
- I'm scared.
- Don't be scared. You're gonna be fine.
- Let's make this ridiculous.
- I, oh Curly.
- (laughing)
- We're gonna do ten push-ups.
- Okay.
- We're gonna 20 split squats
- Do 10 on each leg.
Then we're gonna do 30
or the glute bridges.
- Okay.
- We're gonna do a 40 second plank,
50 jumping jacks and
then 60 seconds of rest.
- 50 in a row?
- Yeah.
- And then do it again?
- And we're gonna do it
again. At least one more time,
maybe two more times. Are you excited?
- Not really.
- You should be.
- (upbeat music)
- See, this is where I
don't like working out.
It's like, you have to be very vulnerable,
and very okay with looking ridiculous.
- (upbeat music)
- Can you hear my heartbeat?
How do people not throw up
when they work out? Because...
- Sometimes they throw up.
- What number are we on?
- (laughing)
- Nine, ten.
- I'm like, not even present
anymore. I'm like, in my brain.
- Honestly though, that's the
part I like about working out.
- That you just let
your body do its thing?
- Mmhmm. Alright, jumping jacks.
- This is like, a really good workout that
I haven't had in a really long time.
- 50.
- Woohoo!
- Now we get to rest again for a minute.
- (uptempo reggae music)
Okay, we're done. So,
would you do it again?
- Yeah actually. I love it,
it's great, I feel really good.
I feel like I'm gonna go
back to my table at my desk
and be like, yeah, you did
something productive today.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- Thanks for working out with me.
- For sure-den.
- I'm glad you didn't hate it.
- No, I loved it. In full...
- Success!
- I'm gonna go shower.
- It was a success. Here's the thing.
Most people who tell you
they like working out
don't like it because they like being
exhausted and sweaty and tired.
They like it because of how
they feel after, so don't
be discouraged if it's hard.
It's supposed to be hard.
You just have to find
something that you don't
totally hate doing and it'll feel like a
cool challenge instead
of like a punishment.